leaving home after killing his mother
with a loaded shotgun he should never
have had in August 2021 Jake Davidson
strolled the streets of Plymouth killing
his victims at random
they included three-year-old Sophie
Martin and her father Lee along with
Davidson's mother Maxine 59 year old
Stephen Washington and 66 year old Kate
Shepard
captured on CCTV with the gun under his
chin
Davison then took his own life
18 months on an inquest Jury has found
how Devin and Cornwall police made
catastrophic failures in granting
Davidson a shotgun certificate which the
victim's family say was essentially a
license to Kill we will never be able to
understand or comprehend why Davidson
did what he did
it was an act of Pure Evil
however
we now know that this evil Act was
facilitated and enabled by a series of
failings and incompetence from the
people and organizations
that are supposed to keep us safe
when 22 year old Davison applied for a
shotgun license he declared his autism
and Asperger's but police failed to get
information from his GP in September
2020 he brutally attacked a teenager in
a skate park police investigating didn't
know he had a shotgun license the
officer was unaware FC on the police
database meant firearm certificate his
weapon was eventually taken away but
despite his history of violence and the
fact his mother had tried to refer him
to the anti-terrorism prevent scheme his
gun was handed back just five weeks
before his shooting spree I am deeply
sorry for the loss of those families and
for the feelings and my force that led
to Jack Davis and having a gun where he
shouldn't have the force says the
application process for a firearms
license has been reformed but the issues
highlighted in this inquest are more
far-reaching this is not just about
failures in one force the jury also
found that a lack of training for
firearms licensing officers was
Nationwide putting Public Safety at risk
the police Watchdog the iopc has issued
a series of recommendations to
strengthen Firearms licensing
I think the bottom line and we've said
this for a long time now is that the
whole process of firearm licensing
ought to be properly resourced we need
also to put shotguns they're just as
lethal on the same par as as rifles
a list of recommendations to police
forces and the home office will be
published in the coming days but for the
victims families this is yet again a
case of too little too late
Dan Whitehead Sky News
in Exeter